what is so maddening is if you look at
the world as we have inherited it you
see that we have the food to feed
everyone we have the resources to
deliver a comfortable life to everyone
what is required is a change of mind
change of mind we need to change our
mind and this is something which people
hate to do but I think very few people
go through life without having to do it
at some point or another and you know
it's actually quite painless and you can
really get into it you just say you know
I said I'd never do that so now I'm
doing it it's very clear that we must
change our minds and the beginning of it
must come from the high tech industrial
democracies the average person on this
planet is black young female third world
and poor that's who's waiting for the
honkey world to get its ass together and
we are at the top of a very narrow
cultural pyramid that has been tolerated
only restlessly to this point and as a
global informational culture begins to
take place people are finding out what
the score is and so it becomes incumbent
upon everyone to change their mind and
this is understood everywhere in the
corporate boardrooms in the military
planning centers everywhere the question
is how shall we change our minds shall
we turn ourselves into
a Ken and Barbie society of
consumeristic robots unquestioningly
following some boiled down ideology that
is essentially one of unquestioned
loyalty unending consumption unending
toleration of stupidity this is one
point of view it's a point of view which
fears people it's an aristocratic
oligarchic point of view the notion that
you know the mob must be controlled if
not opium television if not that
pornography always holding human nature
at bay seeing it as something which if
ever unleashed would roll over the more
delicate sensitivities of a master class
or can there be a return to partnership
a return to work on what has been
spoiled by the father
which means internal work on the
misogyny which is inherent in the most
self-congratulatory and enlightened
bastions of the new age you bet your
booties a world where there is a sense
of global responsibility a sense of a
family a sense of obligation to
ourselves as a tribe and then
secondarily to the environment in which
we have placed ourselves we inherit the
hopes and fears of a thousand
generations of thinking ancestors there
is a mystery embedded in the destiny of
this planet there is this is not
business as usual and history does not
stretch out across the centuries of the
future it isn't like that history is the
generation of a process of singularity
it is anticipated in the magical flight
of shamanism in the Philosopher's Stone
alchemy in the Flying Saucer of modern
syncretic religion it is this
anticipation of a tool-making
intervention into our own fate that
Springs from our own inner resources
this is why the shaman is related to the
Smith because we are literally
attempting to forge the cauldron of our
destiny the container of our post
historical fate the the image of the
cauldron is the image of the maternal
womb we are apparently some kind of
information replicating process embedded
in biology but transcendent to it and
only transiently k in terms of
historical time only transiently can we
do business with biology this is why
history is like an enormous leap over
twenty five thousand years from the cave
paintings at let's go the Venus
figurines the first flutes - you know
departure into our own imagination by
having created a kind of hyper
dimensional electronic coral-reef extra
planetary interiorized exteriorized post
historical culture it's going to happen
one way or another either that I mean
these are our best hopes our worst hopes
are simply Armageddon plague disease and
pushing things back to where they were
before the last ice age I don't relish
that and I think that shamanism is
essentially an anticipation of this
project of care for the planet it is
ecology it is partnership it is
sensitivity to the flowing current of
the DAO it is an awareness of the
frailty
the human vessel and yet a simultaneous
awareness but the transcendental mystery
in its utter transforming splendor
somehow cuts tangential through the low
section of being that we represent this
is what all religions all esoteric
traditions teach but they have taken it
and used it to their own purposes all
these traditions can be traced back to
the worldwide shamanism that spread over
the planet as the last glaciers melted
and it is a tradition I believe of
actually anticipating the future of
actually accessing information that is
drifting back through time from a final
apotheosis of human becoming but
whatever it is that is loose in us it
creates its own self images over and
over again that's what civilization is
technology is the shockwave that follows
upon the revelations of language as we
say it shall be so it becomes and then
we become what we have created this
process of bootstrapping through
language to more and more alien levels
of beauty which we call style art the
revelation of the human soul this is the
vector that points of way out of the
iron prison of Gnosticism and the mute
world of sart's existentialism it is to
recognize and take as one's field of
experience as one's rightful birthright
the full spectrum of human possibilities
so you know it's only been in the last
hundred years that the sexuality could
and be dealt with as a theater for human
self-expression the Victorians put pants
legs on pianos but a greater taboo still
surrounds these interior dimensions
accessible through shamanic means and I
think the the prohibition against
knowing the size the true size of the
universe which is what this is stems
very simply from the fact that all
societies have run their little crap
game based on getting you to buy into
the idea that they knew what they were
talking about and here right next door
exhibit one nobody knows what they're
talking about nobody has anything to say
face to face with the reality of
shamanic ex stasis I mean your jaw hangs
in the wind you have to control yourself
to not just fall to your knees with
tears of joy streaming down your face
and you know then that in in the
watchtowers and on the bridges of human
civilization there ain't nobody home
they're all just making it up I mean the
rich people con the rest of us by
claiming they know what's going on and
this apparently has always been the game
so a shaman knows better shamans have
cut through to a more authentic level of
being it's outside the language web
outside the culture shell and it
literally is another dimension it's a
dimension about which we know absolutely
nothing if we are the prisoners of
culture and language I'm sure many of
you have heard me say a child comes into
the world and the world is as William
James said a blooming buzzing confusion
and then things are isolated a bird on
the windowsill of the child's room and
child through a great effort focused
conveys to its mother that it wants to
know what this is and the mother says
it's a bird it's a bird baby so then
this scintillating blue
self-transforming flying glittering
blowing thing becomes instead a word and
all of reality by the time you're 8
years old is papered over with words
everything has its own explanation this
is a tree this is a microphone this is
dirt and what this is is a patina of
unfeeling a way of neutralizing someone
said language was invented to lie it may
have been not so much invented to lie as
merely to hold meaning at bay because
without the word comes then the
complexity the texture the
interrelatedness the visible past the
anticipated will feature everything
begins to slide apart into what it
really is into you know the ding on C SH
the thing in itself and this is
apparently what culture mitigates
against we find it hard to do business
with each other in large numbers unless
we get this problem of the mutability of
reality nailed down pretty early and get
some specialists lined up who then work
on it and the rest of us can do our
trading and farming unimpeded the
problem is it's too late for business as
usual we are now in a state of planetary
crisis we must find a way to make a
magical flight to another dimension we
must part somehow from the momentum of
history part somehow from the ego
centric Megillah manic dreams of the
dominance of nature that have
characterized Western civilization
and instead we have to relax and find
our way to the dow and my conviction is
that it lies in unleashing our
creativity that if we can use our fear
of the mind of the imagination if we
could say you know not one cultural
innovation per decade but a hundred and
then a thousand and then a minyan we are
poised to become whatever we can imagine
but instead you know we have the
albatross of historical expectation
paternalistic male politics consumerism
you know the litany we must change our
minds by any means necessary and the
shamanic model the model venerated by
tradition the model that in fact lit the
spark in the monkey brain originally and
drew us forward to the threshold of the
adventure of advanced culture must now
in the twilight of advanced
technological culture be reeva the FIDE
and reom powered so that each and all we
can make that magical flight to the
pearl in the well at the end of time and
return with it to our tribe in a way
that inaugurates a kind of golden age
thank you
[Music]
[Music]